non
ce sont des gens comme vous et nous mais
en un instant pour eux tout a basculé
et ils ont vécu l'aventuré de leur vie
ce soir il entre dans la nuit des héros
bonsoir merci
bonsoir à vous tous merci certaines
garcia vous d'être présent nous allons
ce soir encore pour cette troisième
émission de la jour de la nuit des héros
d'hier les journées des héros c'est la
nuit des odeurs
ce soir encore partager l'émotion le
sourire et parfois la joie de gens qui
ont vécu des événements difficiles des
événements exceptionnels ils
s'appelleront ce soir jacky myriam david
et nous les entendrons nous écouterons
ils viendront ici témoigner cette
émission c'est aussi des missions du
coeur au sens propre comme au sens
figuré pourquoi mais parce que notre
héros de la nuit qui s'appelle richard
richard jadot qui se trouve à fréjus
richard va devoir aujourd'hui affronter
des épreuves particulièrement périlleuse
particulièrement délicate voire parfois
dangereuses
ces épreuves au profit d'une fondation
qui s'appelle la fondation du coeur la
marraine en et mireille darc nous aurons
plaisir de la recevoir tout à l'heure et
l'instigateur le créateur de cette
fondation vous l'avez compris bien sûr
il s'agit du professeur cabrol
professeur christian cabrol
voilà merci d'être présent avec nous
merci de passer cette soirée avec nous
ce samedi soir dans la nuit des héros
voici maintenant notre première histoire
de la soirée
nous sommes à toulon il s'appelle david
du moulin il a 17 ans bon si tout se
passe bien c'est relax pour lui c'est
cool comme comme me l'ont dit il doit
avec des copains des copines aller se
promener aller pique-niquer dans un
endroit assez dangereux on appelle ça
les plâtrières ça pour bien son nom
d'ailleurs les plâtrières ce que tu as
et fragile
eh bien il va effectuer un faux pas et
ce faux pas je ne lis pas plus
bonjour
l aventure on ne sait plus très bien
quand on fait une première l'isiq en
tout cas cette bonne impression
c'est un jeu c'est une aventure
il ya un jeu qui se déroule ici ça nous
met une aventure
il ya combien de temps il travaillait
sur ce projet deux en deux ans
et la première fois vous avez unique et
appauvrir
avec
alors justement est-ce que c'est dans la
lignée de l'achat sur presse d'avoir par
exemple des grands jeux déjà approuvés
c'est dans la lignée des grands jeux
conventionnelle des aventures mais ce
n'a rien alors c'est une grande aventure
on va pas dévoiler les secrets on va pas
montrer ce qu'est le jeu on va attendre
toutefois sur l'antenne
combien de personnes travaillent ici à
vendre gars là ils veulent avoir fait un
peu flipper
60 70 par moment du tournage centaines
une centaine de personnes alors dans
quelques jours ce sera là la première de
fabuleuse émission on peut dire que
c'est une première mondiale quasiment
jamais on a mis autant de moyens sommet
on a mis autant de voyages elle a fait
quelque chose d'aussi généralement la
télévision s'est lui départi sophie de
variétés
la nature
alors on fait aussi de la télévision
bien sûr de y avoir une infrastructure
technique considérable est ce qu'on peut
avoir imité dix sept caméras 17 caméras
voilà nous en faut une un reportage et
s'il y en a 17 12 km le table oui 12 km
et
il a fallu
système d'irrigation originaux tout à
fait heureux
tian xi
télécommande
par radio via ses caméras
de quoi on a peur avant première aussi
grand violences de tous notamment
d'avoir oublié le seul c'est comme ça
qu'on fait on a peur d'avoir oublié
je ne sais pas ce qu'on va mouiller on
va sûrement oublié quelque chose au
dernier m'a manqué cinq catastrophes
il faudra toute vitesse retournez à la
côte pour chercher ce sont oubliés
l'ennui c'est que aussi à des vagues des
travaux quart d'heure pour descendre du
bateau
c'est l'heure d'aller fois dans la
courbe et trois quarts d'heure pour
remonter
ses ficelles il peut pas celle là
ma sphère culturelle pour faire plaisir
à pierre arditi à londres il ya une
exposition de mort de bavent de plus des
ces merdeux ce que vous faites est la
bienvenue mais aussi le dit et si vous
aimez l'art contemporain le quotidien
britannique 'the independent' vous
conseille d'aller à londres voir cette
exposition magnifique
ça m'est absolument atteint aujourd'hui
fête culturelle assez solennellement que
j'allais dans une émission intelligente
donc si vous voulez ne pas prendre
complètement ridicule l'invitation
d'ailleurs donc c'est une caisse et à la
souris liam galerie sur williams gary d
zakia la williams gary locke est là sous
ylliam galerie vous avez une jeune femme
qui s'appelle laura godfrey isaac qui
trouvent qu'il faut parler un peu plus
souvent de ces matières de ces
substances plus ou moins corporels que
sont le plus
attendre les faits presqu'île
mais c'est des tableaux ces sont des
tableaux alors sur deux tableaux visuels
je vous ai dit c'est pour vous donc ce
sont des tableaux alors autre chose
autre chose est ce que vous savez
pourquoi l'équipe nationale de côte
d'ivoire de basketball féminin a perdu
le championnat d'afrique
elle avait été à l'exposition tu vas me
dire pourquoi je vais vous dire c'est
l'explication du coup il était au
pouvoir il ya notre temps
la contre-performance pour être trou
mission ad gentes attaques et menaces
qu'ils offraient maison qu'ils habitent
au maire de leur effet quand elle pleure
c'est une catastrophe comme ça comment
j'allais faire pour éviter que ce que
dit est très nerveux lâche ménard me
lâche alors on y va
l'excellent l'air complètement pierre
m on y va regarde pas aucun des trois
oui dit elle et on y va aller au niveau
maghrébin compères elle et non à temps
alors je vous donne la réponse
sa dette de manière je vois rien le
temps la contre performance sportive
pour être être dit ça commence avec la
vie
allez ma mère et ma mère avec mme latour
et vous bonjour ma mère certes ça va
hein
six mois ça gaze mouassa gaza but à gaza
masques à gaz mais tout va très bien
madame de l'ag pas me plaindre
forcément damage d'organiser dans la
cave d'un bâtiment une super méga giga
bout on sera 750 il aura plus de monde
dans ma cave et dans tout le département
étaient et tout ça pour elle pourrait
pour sa belle gueule pour s'y opposer
je vous ai pas dit j'ai rencontré la
femme de ma vie su s'arrêter dans mon
lycée ce matin était là a été magnifique
modèle à l'avancé j'avançais lavancier
j'avançais à l'avancé j'avançais chou
fleur chou fleur chou fleur chou fleur
est monde et on s'est croisés se croiser
là l'âge et les films pulse un parfum
oui c'est ça j'ai dit oui ça sent bon
elle agit là je m'apprêtais à aller lui
acheter des fleurs mais j'ai pas de
thunes et j avais un stylo je lui
rappelle voulez je vous lis les crises
d'accord que vous dire chers geneviève
schehr geneviève je gémis shore n'est
pas parce que j'avais pas trop combien
le premier à la base franchement après
je me suis dit au diable l'avarice elle
quand on aime on ne compte pas cher
geneviève la première fois que j'étais
venu en bâtiment hlm
je me suis dit ça y est c'est toi que je
l'air vous ne voulez pas les affaires
j'ai pas la tête pas je ne voulais même
plus jour basque atteint je ne sais
pourtant que notre amour est impossible
de points a tempéré policiers
s'inquiètent aussi parce que sinon ça
aurait été bien si peu plus tôt par un
policier et moi je suis la cible mais
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] c'est
psychologique que
notre amour vous bien une nuit chez les
flics et moi je lui ai dit les flics
j'ai un trou chez les flics c'est sa
cause d'un filin borgerhout anvers gand
et être salut combattu tu m'aimes pas
regarder même pas répondu jessica des
mois tu voudrais jamais plus ça fait
bien que je fais non franchement
franchement vous verrez jamais plus
jamais plu et j'ai demandé qu'est ce que
tu as vécu m'a dit qu'est ce que vienne
hier soir crochet sur mon premier à
regarder à travers la fenêtre mal fermée
giorgio j'étais fait j'étais grille et
il fallait à tout prix que je lui dise
que je n'avais pas me voir à travers sa
chemise
et puis m'a dit tu sais faire le joint
fouilles dans mon garage commencer celle
qui sait qu'il a dit excusez moi il faut
que je change de page youtube d'artois
pas répondu cette fois ci je le savais
c'était vraiment foutu la regardant
droit devant la tête est bien posée j'ai
décidé de lui dire combien je l'aimé
geneviève geneviève je t'aime beaucoup
sans sympa gentil via ma surprise party
je me lève je te dis encore viens chez
moi j'aime bien j'ai besoin de ton corps
beaucoup avouent d'asseoir sa volée
entre nous si avec l'âge et m'a fait pas
si avec ça je me fais pas et pas
bouleversé que c'est populaire ouais ça
fait ça je me fais pas et brûlèrent
tunique centre sainte-anne jamais il est
tout jeune il vient nous interpréter un
bout de son sketch qui s'appelle l'apnic
avec sa mère voilà
le questionnaire fin d'émission
ces dix questions sont posées à tous les
invités de référence qui viennent dans
cette émission de presque depuis ses
débuts voici ses dc10 question votre
mots préférés woody allen
notre mot m'a fait rire world mon mot
préféré je peux pas vous le dire à la
télévision
table ah bon messi s'est dit lui aussi
si au contraire
vraiment je ne peux pas pourquoi ma mère
ma mère regardent peut-être l'émission
non je ne peux pas le mot que vous
détestez bonjour votre drogue favorite
favorite la leçon le bruit que vous
aimez fn nourrit le bruit ce que je
préfère oui peut-être un coup de coup de
feu ah bon et le coup de feu sur
broadway et et le son le bruit que vous
détestez dont je n'aime pas le son de ma
voix votre juron gros mots ou blasphème
favori m'a fait valoir mon quoi on vous
êtes en colère je ne suis pas comme ça
quand je suis en colère je suis très
désagréable quand je suis en colère
quand vous n'aimeriez pas vous
n'aimeriez pas cependant je peux pas
prendre de risques qu'une qu'un de mes
proches ou admet être cher m'entends
dire ça non non non non c'est trop
violent
non non non non je peux pas vraiment pas
aimé c'est peut-être le premier mot que
vous vouliez pas prononcé à la première
question il ya certes il ya beaucoup
d'autres mots petit que vous avez bien
le métier que vous n'auriez pas aimé
faire oui jo quel métier out night by
n'aurait pas voulu qu'elle se présente
moi nous être gardien de prison par
exemple
bien la plante l'arbre où l'animal dans
lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné
bonne question que j'aimerais peut-être
être réincarné en éponge on éponge
oui mais pourquoi pour gonfler et
lavabos coûteux c'était joli ses
sympathies nos ennemis à l'aller les
punchs n'a pas d'ennemi est soit naïve
et pourquoi pas est la dernière question
qui est plus difficile si dieu existe si
dieu existe qu'aimeriez vous après votre
mort l'entendre vous dire à vous woody
allen a effeuillé bio je te pardonne
fils s'ils existent je pense que je
risque d'avoir de gros problèmes très
bien